rescue of 1174 people from Wuhan China
and the diamond Princess cruise ship in
Japan is a testament to the agility
proficiency and dedication of our
workforce our interagency partnerships
and others to accomplish our core
mission advancing the interests of the
American people following the SARS
outbreak of 2004 the US Government
Accountability Office recommended that
the department work with interagency
partners and the private sector to
develop capabilities to support the
medical evacuation and transportation of
US citizens from areas impacted by the
sudden outbreak of infectious disease in
the 2014 Ebola virus disease outbreak
again served as a reminder that the
department must have a standing Crisis
Response aviation capability to protect
the u.s. employees and citizens when
emergency situations arise such a such a
prompt repatriation of US citizens from
quarantined conditions could not have
been possible had it not been for the
bureau of medical services existing
aviation contract and solid corporate
partners the unmasked contract is the
department's only standing response
aviation support and critical care
medical evacuation capability and the US
government's only standing
biocontainment transport capability upon
receipt of the mission directives we
managed to configure and simultaneously
choreograph the movement of five
aircraft including the the coordination
of all flight clearances over flights
and other required logistics Department
of State personnel on board these
aircraft were trained and equipped to
manage these operations the Department
successfully directed and executed a
total of seven flights over four
missions but the vacuous transported to
five different locations within the
United States equipped to safely receive
evaluate and house persons exposed to
the virus this operation involved close
coordination with our interagency
partners including the Federal Aviation
Administration and the department's of
Defense Health and Human Services
Homeland Security and others we also
chord
with international partners including
the governments of the People's Republic
of China Japan the Republic of Korea and
Canada I was the lead Medical Service
Officer overseeing these missions and
led the 2nd and 3rd mission on the
ground in Wuhan some 41 countries and
territories have reported cases of kovat
19 infection placing the health of our
employees and US citizens in these
countries and territories at risk in
these unprecedented times the
department's medical professionals are
committed to doing everything we can for
the health and safety of our workforce
and the US citizens overseas in summary
I'd like to thank each of you for your
continued support as we keep pace with
this international emergency we know
that your support to the department the
bureau medical services in particular
has made this all possible and that your
continued support will be critical in
the months and years to come thank you
thank you dr. Walters director Redfield
well thank you chairman Baron and
ranking member yo and the members of the
committee for the opportunity to speak
to you today CDC the Department of
Health and Human Services the State
Department and other US government
partners are fully committed to confront
the serious global health threat
presented by coronavirus disease 19
CDC's public health approach to Kovan 19
is built on decades of infectious
disease expertise and prior public
health emergencies such as SARS MERS
Ebola and pandemic influenza our goal is
to keep America safe and to slow the
introduction of this new virus into the
United States our response involves
multi-layered aggressive containment and
potential mitigation measures as needed
these proven health proven effective
public health interventions include
early diagnosis isolation and contact
tracing these public health
interventions also include targeted
travel restrictions as well as the use
of quarantine for individuals returning
from transmission hot zones such as who
Bay Province China and the Diamond
Princess cruise ship docked in Japan
internationally CDC is working with
the World Health Organization and
ministries of health across the globe to
continue to combat this outbreak CDC has
deployed over 600 staff to the response
including staff supporting Japan South
Korea and our country office in China
this outbreak underscores our national
leadership role on the global scale and
then Sesa t of strengthening our global
capacity to stop disease threats at
their source before they spread with
this out when this outbreak was first
reported in December 2019 China reported
27 cases of pneumonia linked to a
seafood market today there's more than
78 thousand cases in over 2,700 deaths
over the past two months we've seen
confirmed cases reported in 46
international locations including the
United States and several of these
countries now are supporting our
reporting and sustained community spread
in the United States 15 cases have been
confirmed by our nation's public health
and medical community based on clinical
guidance provided them by CDC On
February 26 CDC confirmed an infection
with the virus caused by Cove in 19 and
a person who reportedly did not have any
relevant travel history or exposure to
other COBIT patients it's possible this
could be an instant in instance of
community spread of Coban which would be
the first time this has happened in the
United States three cases have been
detected among the Americans repatriated
from Wuhan and another 43 cases were
confirmed among the crippled cruise ship
passengers that were repatriated from
Japan we commend the efforts of the
Government of Japan to institute a
quarantine measures onboard the ship and
we appreciate Japan's cooperation with
the United States government to evaluate
and care and evacuate American citizens
CDC works in partnership with the State
Department to assist in this
repatriation effort of American system
citizens both from China and Japan all
of the individuals repatriated from
Wuhan by the State Department Charles
charters have now been released from
their mandatory quarantine these
individuals are not at risk of spreading
virus to others and should return to
their normal lives passengers from the
diamond princes are in the process of
completing their quarantine at several
locations across the United States we
are grateful to all the Americans who
have and still are undergoing quarantine
for their patience and their cooperation
as well as their willingness to ensure
that they their families their
communities and our nation remain safe
we also want to thank the Department of
Defense the military personnel their
families on the Intel eight
installations where the vacuum vacuous
have been quarantined for their
hospitality and service to our nation
efforts to direct flights from mainland
China to 11 US airports continue CDC is
working closely with Customs and Border
Protection to screen arriving passengers
from mainland China for illness and to
identify people at high risk of exposure
to this new virus and ensure that they
were referred for the appropriate public
health follow-up to inform future
travelers of the virus and where it's
spreading CDC continues to post travel
advisories and alerts specifically China
and South Korea are now level three
warnings that abide advise travelers
against non-essential travel finally CDC
is current current assessment into the
United States is the risk of this
infection remains low however we do
anticipate new community cases we have
implemented a successful containment
strategy but we must be prepared to move
to a blended containment mitigation
approach we also need to make sure we
continue to strengthen our public health
infrastructure is alluded to by the
Chairman and is ready for broader
community spread CDC and HHS will
continue to keep members of Congress
informed the new developments we
recognize that you are trusted leaders
in your community and communication with
the public is essential during this
immediate emergency thank you and I look
forward to your questions thank you
director I will now turn to my opening
questions and then I'll recognize the
ranking member and our other members for
five minutes for the purpose of
questioning the witness
director in my opening statement as well
as you alluded to it in your opening
statement of this potential first
patient community spread and it is in my
home county Sacramento County at and the
patient's house at the hospital that I
used to attend in and have taught lots
of medical students in you know in
talking to my colleagues earlier today
and getting a sense of you know the the
the timeline of this patient one thing
is a bit concerning
you know I've taken care of patients
like this you get transferred who are
intubated who you don't have a sense of
what the respiratory diagnosis is you
know cultures are coming back negative
etc and in this case it does seem like
last Wednesday the medical staff asked
for a test of Khurana virus and was
we're told this patient didn't meet
their criteria and this was not a corona
virus patient as a patient worsened it
does sound like this past Sunday there
was an insistence and a strong push and
and ultimately the patient did get
tested and we know the results that came
back 72 hours later as a positive test a
question that I'd have and maybe it's
twofold number one what current criteria
are we using to determine who's going to
get a test and who's not going to get a
test you know when when a doctor caring
for this patient and they're looking at
a patient they request that it's a
no-brainer we ought to do that test
based on the the medical expertise of
the the folks that are trying to come
confirm a diagnosis at a minimum with
this new case we ought to rethink what
those criteria are and I'd be curious to
hear what criteria were using today and
if the CDC is updating that criteria and
then the second component is it is a our
our testing capabilities seem a bit too
slow at this juncture and I'd be curious
to hear what we're doing to increase the
rapidity and availability of tests if we
are getting testing kits out to all 50
state
as well as you know more broadly to you
know cities and others and then you know
did take 72 hours to from testing to get
the results and you know if we could get
those testing facilities a little bit
closer I'd be curious to see how CDC is
thinking about that and I'm also told
one of my sister institutions UCSF
they've produced a more rapid test need
the ability to get some samples to to
confirm the the the specificity and
sensitivity of that test and there's
some private sector companies that are
also working on rapid diagnostic tools
as well so dr. Redfield mr. chairman
chairman thank you for the questions
first I think you know when this
outbreak started for better or worse
even in China it was linked to whether
you were exposed to the sea market so
our food market so obviously every
confirmed case was from the market and
then that when discussions I had with
the Chinese CDC director I suggested
they go out and look at other people
with flu-like illness and of course and
they reported that there were many cases
that weren't on the market when the
United States began this Pui we we had
the epidemiological advantage of a link
to obey initially where most the cases
came from clearly what's been
demonstrated by the recent case is
that's no longer operational I will tell
you that as soon as that case was
recognized we met and we revised our
case definition for persons under
investigation and I'm I'm I'm today that
has been posted along with a new health
advisory that the recommendations should
be when a clinician or a public health
individual suspects coronavirus then
then we should be able to get a test for
coronavirus so that's the current
guidance that went out today and this is
a fluid situation and your second
question is also critical how do we
expand the availability of testing we
think it was an accomplishment to within
a week to develop a test that we could
get eyes on this and I think the CDC
scientists were able to do that but what
that was not to take away the broader
responsibility for the private sector to
become in to be able to provide broader
testing for
the non public health community we've
had aggressive discussions about how to
expand that and we are continuing
we have shipped our kids as you know
initially out to many many jurisdictions
we had trouble with one of the controls
that has now been corrected and they're
now 40 jurisdictions that have the
ability to do the tasks modified with
the FDA approval and in the next today
tomorrow we anticipate more kids from
the private sector that have been
contracted by CDC to get out and
hopefully our real goal is at LabCorp
and Mayo Clinic and others well you get
at the root of it why is there a
difference and I used to run a
diagnostic lab and develop tests the
other countries have the ability for
someone like me to develop a laboratory
test and to deploy it in our country we
develop a laboratory test and we need to
go through a regulatory process in order
to get it deployed and again I'm not
criticizing the regulatory process I'm
just saying that's the difference and
many labs in this country many hospitals
could stand up as you mentioned San
Francisco another your own you know
Davis could stand up a test within in
several days because we've published the
sequences and the methods and exactly
how to do this and that's how that one
company IDT as now is now ready to sell
a test which is really basically a copy
of the CDC test so I do think we have to
look at that because this is an example
where we were slowed in a sense because
of the way we want to assure accuracy of
these diagnostic tests and I know you
all are wrestling with that but we are
having work hits out later today they're
going to be sent to the states the state
of California I talked to your Secretary
of Health
just today because they were down to 200
tests we're sending more out there there
are three laboratories now I'm told in
California that have the ability to do
the tests I'm saying but both of your
points are very very important we take
them very seriously one of the least
we've not going to let happen again
because we corrected it after the first
case and the other we're working hard to
get these tests out and hoping that the
private sector comes in for the clinical
use CDC develops them for the public
health use and we need the private
sector to come in for the clinic
director I appreciate the change in the
criteria and applaud that I do think
this is a unique situation where we need
all hands on deck and we do need to take
a look at speeding up the regulatory
process we do need to allow the
academics and those that have the
ability to develop their own testing
capabilities to quickly move through the
process to make sure these are sensitive
and specific an accurate diagnostic test
and then if the private sector can
augment our ability now there may be
community spread we've got to stop the
bottleneck and we've got to get these
out to all parts of the country so we
can take that up here but you're looking
at the administration whatever we can do
to speed up that regulatory process to
make testing readily available to the
practitioners that are out there yeah
with that let me recognize the ranking
member you know I appreciate it and I
appreciate y'all's testimony and I think
what you're just bringing up is a lot of
the questions I had you know the assume
it's a PCR test or analyze test okay the
variation in those you guys created that
and I think along that lines there
should be provisional approvals quickly
and that's thing if you guys are in a
bottleneck where you can't get that let
us know so we can help relieve that and
then do the testing and verification
down the road but you have to have a
place to start and then when we get into
the point where we have private
manufacturing of these we just need to
make sure that we're all on the same
page it's the same test so we don't have
a variation in sensitivity or
specificity and that we need to make
sure that other countries are doing the
same my concern is you know with so much
of the API is being created in China
about 80 85 % plus is what I've heard
you know I look at it from a national
security standpoint you're our national
health standpoint not just our country
but other countries you know if somebody
needs Advil and you've got a population
of 1.3 billion people you know are they
gonna service their customers first
before over here and I think this is a
wake-up call for American manufacturers
and our pharmaceutical countries not to
be dependent on a country what are your
thoughts about that
whoever once tackle at mr. fritz you're
the one Thank You ranking member Yoho
there's clearly going to be all sorts of
economic impacts as the as the outbreak
continues to develop we are paying very
very close attention to not just the
general macro name macroeconomic impacts
that are going to occur with regard to
the United States economy and other
economies around the world but also to
the impacts on supply chains and
particularly as you mentioned supply
chains that are important to our ability
to react to future instances future
outbreaks I don't have anything that I
can share with you right now
ranking member in terms of what those
responses will look like but it is
something that we're looking at very
clear carefully and we have people
across the interagency process who are
actively considering ways we can make
sure that we are able to make sure that
we do have access to the necessary
supply chains all right let me ask about
the cooperation do you guys feel that
the cooperation is adequate with the
Chinese government as far as
transparency just working side by side
or do you feel like it's here's the
information we'll give you and kind of
guarded so why don't I take a shot at
that on certainly with regards to the
evacuation of our personnel and American
citizens very diplomatically and
logistically challenging I would have to
say that we were able to achieve a very
high level of coordination with the
relevant Chinese authorities to make the
five flights that we got into and out of
Wuhan happen they weren't easy but we
did in fact we were able to rely on our
Chinese counterparts and working with us
to make sure that those succeeded do you
feel like they're treating all the
countries that way cuz we heard the
reports that they weren't letting the
Taiwanese out I would be able to
characterize whether they've been able
by then treating everyone as well as
they've been treating us I do know that
they have worked well with a number of
other partners but I have heard the
similar reports about our friends from
Taiwan being treated differently with
regard to their evacuation plans
I would say on in general however I
think the the PRC authorities have
generally made good-faith efforts to
help evacuate folks from Wuhan of other
nationalities
does anybody have reports about this
being in North Korea which I would
assume it is I mean do we have any
definitive proof we don't have any
confirmed reports yeah okay
let's see I think with that mr. chairman
I'm gonna yield back and I appreciate
everybody here I look forward to the
questions and I'm gonna gather some more
information so thank you all and you
know I know working together as you are
we will be prepared for this in the
United States and hopefully we can be
the ones that help the other countries
the most Thank You great gentleman from
Michigan mr. Levin is recognized to
question witness for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman on Tuesday
Nancy Missoni a the director of the
National Center for immunization
respiratory diseases at the CDC said
this of coronavirus ultimately we expect
we will see community spread in the
United States it's not a question of if
this will happen but when this will
happen and how many people in this
country will have severe illnesses but
National Economic Council director Larry
Kudlow then said we have contained this
I won't say it's airtight but it's
pretty close to airtight end quote and
also this is all on Tuesday President
Trump said the corona virus in the
United States quote that it's under
control and a quote problem that's going
to go away so that was all on the same
day Americans are scared of this
situation and they want to know what's
being done to keep them safe and hearing
mixed messages like this within the span
of hours isn't
reassuring dr. Redfield how can the
virus be both a problem that's going
away and also not a question of if
but when what should we be telling our
constituents about what to expect thank
you very much I think it's a very very
important question right now at this
stage and I've said this and I continue
to say it the risk to the American
public is low we have an aggressive
containment strategy that really has
worked up to this time 15 cases in the
United States until the case that we
just had in Sacramento we hadn't had a
new case in two weeks we do believe
we're going to continue to see new cases
and we do believe now there may be the
initial cluster occurrence of a
community acquisition some countries
this has moved very quickly like we saw
in Korea now where we had more cases in
Korea last in the last 24 hours and we
had in all China right we see it in
Italy it's moving fast Iran it's moving
fast but other countries have really
used in containment and in a blended
mitigation strategy like Singapore and
Hong Kong and they've really limited the
spread after the initial introduction
from China we're of the point of view
that we're still an aggressive
containment mode and which is dependent
on early case recognition isolation and
contact tracing that now is going to be
looking to identify these community
introductions and practice public health
to minimize them but at the same time
we've done this to give us time and I
think what dr. metier was trying to say
I think it was maybe could have been
done much more articulately forefront
than what the American public heard what
she was trying to say it's also a good
time for us to prepare if we have to go
to more mitigation we're still committed
aggressively to get aggressive
containment and I think I want the
American public to know at this point
that the risk is low I want them to know
that we are going to start identifying
more cases like we did the other day I'm
going to ask them to obviously
accelerate their own view
of the standard things that we do for
flu hand-washing coughing your sleeve
don't go to work or school if you're
sick
and we are we have launched a larger for
our next level of our multi-layered
public health response is to now
institute broad surveillance and we've
initiated it we're planning over the
hopefully the new in the next four eight
weeks
obviously linked to the Supplemental to
actually make our surveillance system
for Corona the same as flu nationwide so
we can be you know very quickly picking
up when there is an introduction in a
community go in and try to stop it so I
think that's our position at this point
good but let me quickly ask you one
other question my limited time I want to
ask you to speak about the danger of
xenophobia in a situation like this CNN
reported last month on disturbing
example from the SARS outbreak when and
quoting them people of Asian descent
were treated like pariahs in the West
there were reports of white people
covering their faces in the presence of
Asian co-workers and real estate agents
who were told not to serve Asian clients
and quote we saw similar incidents
during the h1n1 swine flu outbreak in
2009 and during the 2014 Ebola outbreak
and sadly I've heard reports of
incidents like this around coronavirus
so I'd like you to talk about why it's
so important to avoid stereotyping
people as carriers of the corona virus
and how incidents like these can be
avoided and how they're dangerous really
for Public Health
I couldn't agree with you more for those
who've heard me talk before I've always
said that stigma is the enemy of Public
Health in all its forms whether it's in
dealing with HIV whether it's dealing
with drug use disorder whether it's
dealing with obesity whether it's
dealing with their response to the
corona virus at this time stigma has no
role no place in public cause it's
counterproductive so I think we're gonna
have to proactively get that message out
to the American people so that we don't
harm our own public health with with
stereotypes folks might have don't you
agree yeah I will continue to actu it
and I think you make an important
point cuz we have you know we have seen
those reports and I think again we need
to react oh that stigma has no role
thank you and thank you mr. Chairman I
yield back
thank you the gentleman from Florida mr.
Massey is recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman mr. redfield I
want to start with you and you spoke
specifically about early diagnosis being
part of the the positive that's going on
here can you discuss with me what our
early symptoms which lead to early
diagnosis you know I think the first
thing I want to say is there's a lot we
don't know and we're learning more each
day that's what concerns those of us
that are confronting this if it was flu
we understand flu well we there's a lot
we don't know but what we have learned
in the last eight weeks is that this
virus can actually cause a symptomatic
infection no symptoms now that's
complicated when you're dealing with a
public health threat if you can have it
and on the on the princess ship over 50
percent of the individuals that were
diagnosed in the process in Japan lack
symptoms now there may be an ascertain
man issue because they thought if they
had symptoms they'd be treat different
but clearly there's a significant
percentage of people that lack some
symptoms and there's clear evidence now
that we've learned those individuals can
actually transmit the virus so it's the
Chairman knows from a public health
point of view that that makes this more
complicated the other side of it it's
symptoms can be as negligible as a
scratchy throat a dry cough and you can
see that's why initially we had Pui
definitions that were pretty narrow
because if all of a sudden everybody
with a scratchy throat or a dry coughed
or and flu season came then we we had
some complexities at the severe end it
can cause really a very significant
pneumonia respiratory compromise
requiring critical care and overall it
does look like five to same five percent
of individuals in the China situation or
critical 15 need critical care other
countries are starting to show similar
but on the other spectrum there can be
this asymptomatic ill
so we're still learning it's complicated
obviously in the individual case that we
talked about here where severe pneumonia
and otherwise healthy individual in
light of what we now know that in the
prompt the medical community to consider
the corona virus and the differential
diagnosis but a lot of individuals may
just present with a sore throat and a
dry cough let me go to the other side of
the table eighty plus thousand cases
diagnosed and the number that I've read
is 33,000 recovered in mainland China
recovered from having the diagnosis can
you say what has been a chief factor
that has led to those that have
recovered through it is that something
that we know I think there's probably
two major factors one or I get maybe
three one is age and what is
comorbidities so individuals that happen
to have diabetes or hypertension or
chronic obstructive lung disease and
happen to be elderly these individuals
have a much higher mortality but the
other issue that needs to be stressed is
the effectiveness of the healthcare
system so in wuhan the mortality right
now is somewhere over four percent their
health system is beyond strained before
this outbreak they had 132 I think
isolation beds for infectious disease
today they have over 20,000 now you can
go from 132 beds to 20,000 you can build
the structures but as the chairman knows
where the doctors where are the nurses
where are the ventilators where is the
trained healthcare professionals so we
see a mortality and we believe it's the
integrity of the health system that is a
major factor because if you just go to
the rest of China the mortality is
probably about a half a percent okay so
I think I think the major factors I
would say with comorbidities age in the
and the resilience of the health system
that you happen to be in when you get
sick if you don't have access to oxygen
where tau is gonna be a lot higher
that's why we're worried about Pakistan
Afghanistan Bahrain you know North
Africa all the countries that have come
on board recently many of them don't
have health systems that are going to be
a
sustained life in the presence of Paula
nari compromised this is something you
have a lot more faith in our health
system obviously than Wuhan or pick any
of the other countries that you just
listed off yeah I think we we're in a
strong position we have an effective
health care system I you know I think
you know at this stage if we can
continue to do what we're trying to find
these community cases get our arms
around them I think we can continue to
respond obviously if the numbers get to
the point that we can't control then
that's a different a totally different
part of game yeah totally a different
issue but right now is he there because
my time is about to end just to say I
think you you mentioned something that
is important to realize about this that
our health system has a different
starting point than that health system
of Wuhan and many other places certainly
doesn't make us impervious to this but
it's a better starting place to be at
thank you for your comments thank you
mister masks the gentlelady from
Pennsylvania mr. Lanz recognized for
five minutes question the witness
thank you I'm actually going to start I
know that it's my obligation in some
ways to ask complicated questions about
policy but dr. Redfield I'd actually
like to start and lead off of mr.
Levin's conversation for the human
beings who are at home you know my kids
my family members my community and asked
the doctor who you are the 18th director
of the Center for Disease Control and
Prevention and administrator of the
agency for toxic substances and disease
registry and in your capacity could you
help me to answer a few questions that I
frequently get asked the first one they
can be any answer I don't know the
answers I'm just asking on behalf of my
community should people be afraid thank
you what could you turn on your
microphone sure should people engage in
regular hand washing and coughing into
their sleeves absolutely should people
be stocking up on cleaning supplies no
should people be stocking up on
prescription medications that they have
not at this time
should people be stocking up on food
supply not
this time should you wear a mask if
you're healthy no and is there a website
and you can answer this later if you
don't know it by heart where people can
go to access good information about
these questions
absolutely the CDC cdc.gov we have all
of the information on that website then
when in a something can take you to
coronavirus and where we are and any
preparedness and all our recommendations
and sir is there anything else that I
should have asked you that's a regular
everyday person kind of question the one
comment I would make because I do see
people feeling and need to go buy masks
and I would ask them and some people
scoff at me when I say this we need to
make sure those in ninety-five masks are
available for the doctors and nurses
that are going to be taking care of
individuals that have this illness and
it really does displease me to find
people going out there's no role for
these masks in the community these mass
need to be prioritized for health care
professionals as part of their job or
taking care of individuals and/or
individuals who have this virus enter in
home isolation a home quarantine for
those family members so I'd like to have
the prioritize the uses that we
recommend and and get people to realize
that that's where these masks need to be
reserved for thank you I appreciate that
and with the last couple of minutes of
my questioning I think this is either
for mr. fritz or for dr. Redfield based
on how people have answered questions
I'm going to follow up on the line of
questioning that has to do with
prescription and pharmaceutical supply
chains and the integrity of the supply
chain is there a place a way that we
have historically been tracking various
supply chains in my old business we
would make sure that we had at least two
or three suppliers of the same material
just in case is there something that we
have a database or other system that
tracks those kinds of suppliers and
where they are geographically thank you
a congresswoman for the question
as I mentioned there is a very intense
interagency process underway
I think HHS in particular or the Food
and Drug Administration and other
relevant agencies are all looking very
carefully at this exact question and
making sure that the answer to that
question going forward is that we do
have access to whatever we need to
sustain ourselves in the current
outbreak and to make sure that we're
ready for future ones so I understand
that the FDA largely is you know sort of
lead on this but is there a role that
the State Department can play on this is
there something that we at this body can
do to be helpful in that the State
Department is doing is what we're
looking very closely at the impact of
the outbreak on our global supply chains
and of course we're working with some of
our other Foreign Affairs and Trade
related agencies to map that out and
then we're again together with HHS and
others looking at how that impacts our
ability to access what we need in time
of crisis here in the country yeah and
I'm just looking for this to be sort of
a sad lessons learned you know how can
we take this experience and make sure
that doesn't happen to us again how can
we make sure we know where our supplies
suppliers are and and how to make sure
that we are safe from this kind of
exposure again yes ma'am I mean I think
this crisis is teaching us that we need
to pay very very close attention to this
and the era of globalized supply chains
and we are bound and determined to make
sure that whatever lessons are learned
from this are applied going forward
thank you and with my last half a minute
of conversation I just wanted to kind of
take off on something we were we were
happy that our health care system was
better than Wuhan that's awesome but can
you comment a little bit more about how
we need to work with other nations to
make sure all of our health care systems
are working on together in tandem on
this thank you for that question ma'am I
would like to point out that u.s.
foreign assistance over a number of
years now has focused in large part on
helping countries around the world build
public health systems that are able to
be resilient in the face of these sorts
of crises of course this that is being
put to the test in many instances I
think what we can say is things probably
would be much worse if it had not been
for our efforts over a number of years
to to share best practices and actually
make resources available to build
capacity around the world in this aspect
and of course we have announced up to
100 million dollars of assistance for
partners around the world to respond to
the Koba 19 crisis thank you I've run
out of time I yield back
Thank You mr. Lam the gentleman from
Ohio mr. Chabot recognized the question
the witness for five minutes thank you
very much mr. chairman mr. fruits I'll
direct my question that you if I if I
can I was one of the original founding
co-chairs of the Congressional Taiwan
caucus and I'm now one of the co-chairs
of that that caucus and as you know and
as we all know the PRC china considers
Taiwan a breakaway province Taiwan for
all intents and purposes conducts itself
as an independent nation not necessarily
recognized by the world as such but it
is and the people there are free they
ought to be a model to other countries
around the globe they've been bullied by
the PRC for many years now but my
question is this they have sought to be
recognized observer status basically at
that whu-oh for many years in my view
they ought to be essentially a fully
recognized participant in the w-h-o it's
kind of a gap in our world health system
in not recognizing them not letting them
fully participate but at this point
China is still blocked them from so
participating with something as serious
as the corona virus and obviously its
origins in the PRC in China and Taiwan
being right next door in Taiwan having
some of the top medical institutions and
doctors medical personnel in the world
there you know it seems to make no sense
that that China continues in this effort
Taiwan could be helpful even more
helpful to China so so what gap does
this create in the world's response to
this various serious medical
and and the situation we have with the
current of our what what what's the
problem with what what China is doing a
relative to to Taiwan thank you very
much for the question congressman as you
said Taiwan is a is a robust democracy
it's a model in that respect it's a
reliable partner on public health and a
number of other concerns that we share
and it's a force for good in the world
it couldn't agree more and I think this
Cove in nineteen out break only further
underlines the unacceptability of Taiwan
being excluded from the World Health
Organization the World Health Assembly
because the People's Republic of China
blocks every attempt for it to do so as
you mentioned not only has the Cova 19
outbreak affected Taiwan they have 30
some cases there and to the to the
extent that they are unable to get
timely information from the whu-oh that
impacts Public Health on Taiwan on the
other hand as you pointed out Taiwan has
a lot of expertise and they have some
experience and in fact they have their
own you know epidemiological you know
track record now dealing with koban 19
and to the extent that that is not being
shared in a complete and timely fashion
with other wo members clearly that
doesn't do anything for the public
health of the rest of the international
community which is of course why the
United States has and continues to push
very hard for Taiwan to have meaningful
participation in the WTO and to be a
granted observer status at the World
Health Assembly China it's worth
pointing out that the People's Republic
of China was okay with Taiwan being an
observer back when a different party was
in power in Taiwan so through 2016
Taiwan did have observer status at the
whao it's only when when when the
wouldn't when the Democratic the DPP
party came into power in 2016 the china
became blocking across the board a
taiwan participation and we continue to
push back very very hard against that
with as many of our like-minded partners
as possible and i think our argument is
only bolstered now by the coab in
nineteen outbreak and I would point out
that you know this push by the USG is
fully consistent with our u.s. one China
policy and of course with the Taiwan
relations
which governs unofficial relations
between the United States and Taiwan
thank you very much my times almost
expired so let me just reiterate what
you said I agree with all the points
that you made thank you for that and I
want to thank the administration for
continuing to be a friend to Taiwan and
we would encourage it to continue to do
so even even step that up and it's a
shame that that the PRC China allows its
intransigence with respect Taiwan to put
not only the people of Taiwan and its
own people but the rest of the world
more at risk than we ought to be so they
ought to they ought to do the right
thing here and allow Taiwan not just to
be observer status but to be a full
member of the World Health Organization
that whu-oh thank you very much Thank
You mr. Chabot the gentleman from Rhode
Island mr. Cicilline is recognized
question witness for five minutes
thank you and mr. Chairman I want to
thank you for the courtesy in allowing
me to participate in this hearing thank
you to our witnesses for their testimony
dr. Redfield I want to ask you kind of
to follow up a little bit on miss
Houlihan's question about the supply
chain because as you described this
potential pandemic becoming really a
global challenge I guess it already is
by by most estimates what what are we
doing to assure that there's a
sufficient supply of you know medical
supplies you mentioned oxygen I mean do
we have a coordinating body that's
figuring out if this pandemic proceeds
in a serious way in this country that
will have access to the resources we
need both for the kind of containment
you've spoken about in treatment and is
there someone doing that sort of
planning yes that's not really within
what I do at CDC but I will tell you
that the assistant secretary for
preparedness response asper is done
extensive work and it was as was
mentioned by mr. France Chris there's an
interagency group that's really going
through this in quite detail with the
FDA and and asper in terms of many of
the medical issues but
as a broader inter government group
doing it in the broader issues and so I
can tell you that's ongoing and we could
obviously get to you who's the
leadership on it but I know aspirin FDA
have done it on the medical side and
there is a broader an intergovernmental
working group to really get down to all
of these issues right and you also made
reference to the Chinese CDC or
counterpart can you speak a little bit
about the relationship between the CDC
in the US and the Chinese particularly
as it relates I'm particularly
interested in this health care worker
transmission two weeks ago China
reported 1,700 health care workers had
been affected by coronavirus and just
wondering what we're learning about that
transmission and whether or not that's
informing protocols here in this country
to protect our health care workers yes
thank you
the CDC has had now over a 30-year
working relationship with China CDC
there's a reason they call it China CDC
and I actually have a US CDC component
that's a affiliated with the embassy but
is it attached to the China CDC the
chair of the head of CDC China and I
have been in regular discussions since
the very beginning when this happened on
New Year's Eve and had very open
scientific discussions about what he
knew at the time what he was learning so
we could use that information and that
continues bi-directionally as I as I say
from the V you know at the beginning
there was not a thought that there was
human to human transmission and no Zuko
meal front transmission they saw that
you know in the first week they didn't
see any in the second week but remember
they were using you know a definition of
whether people were very severely ill
they weren't recognizing that this could
be mildly symptomatic since then there's
obviously an extensive hospital based
transmission in one series that was
published in one of our journals in JAMA
recently showed that up to 40% of the
cases got infected either because they
were health care workers or because they
went into a hospital where they were
infected after they got there so
healthcare transmission
is really a high risk particularly in
areas that really aren't vigilant in the
importance of infection control we're
happy to say to date we haven't had a
healthcare worker
obviously the new case as was mentioned
by the chairman raises concern because
people were intubated and not
necessarily in precautions that were
aggressively evaluating that and doctor
who could you just give us a quick
update on the vaccine development status
and whether or not additional resources
are necessary what the timetable looks
like for that I think lots of people are
interested in that
sure well the NIH doctor pouchy has the
lead on this but I can tell tell you
what he's told us and others is that
they do have a candidate product that
they are planning to move into a phase
one trial hopefully in the next six
weeks which will evaluate immunity Nissa
T and safety assuming that that
candidate and they've partnered already
with a private sector company and
assuming that goes well then they would
move into an expanded Phase two trial
and but in reality if everything goes
really well and they get the strategic
partners that they need he's saying he
looks at a year to 18 months
before we could happen we do believe
scientifically that this is a virus that
should be able to have a successful
vaccine based on the corona virus as
opposed if we were trying to do this say
for HIV you know we would say well we
don't know because we're not sure how
that's gonna work or not but for this
virus there's a lot of scientific reason
to think that it will be successful and
the NIH is really moving forward very
aggressively to try to make that happen
thank you thank you mr. chairman I yield
back the gentlelady from Virginia and
mrs. Bamberger is recognized for five
minutes
thank you very much thank you to the
witnesses for being here and as you
might imagine I am very concerned about
this the issue of this virus and
constituents across central Virginia the
district I represent are deeply
concerned so I want to start by
saying thank you dr. Redfield for what
you said to my colleague representative
Houlihan which is that they shouldn't be
afraid I think that's incredibly
important I appreciate you being here
today to talk about this important issue
but also to mention that because so much
of how we are handling this this disease
this outbreak will also be determined by
how we're communicating and what the the
temperament and feeling on the ground is
I wanted to speak very briefly about
some local preparedness it in dr. riffle
I'll I'll start with you the corona
virus is expected to put additional
strain on our healthcare system and
you've noted that our healthcare
providers are already at near max
capacity due to a bad flu season how is
the federal government ensuring that
medical providers across the country
have what they need and the resources
that they need and and what else could
we be doing a very important question
and I want to say that my partnership
agency and in the Health and Human
Services asper has been working and
continues to work to see that hospitals
begin to get prepared that's one of
their essential mission missions to the
assistant secretary for response and
preparedness asper and so they're are
going through that in great detail
they've had dialogues with different
Hospital corporations this hospital
leaders to begin to see that because you
do say that this you know for us there's
there's not a lot of flex in our health
system right now I mean most hospitals
right now because of influenza if you're
looking at them they may be at 95 96 97
% capacity this is why I stress that our
current public health response that
multi-layered response is containment
containment containment containment to
try to bias time for the fruits of
Labor's by NIH and dr. pouchy and the
private sector so hopefully in the
not-too-distant future in a year year
and a half two years we'll have a
vaccine but I can tell you a spur is
very aggressively working and evaluating
this and try to the term they use is
Brazil
to try to make sure they can from build
resilience into the system and following
up on that notion of containment in
order to contain we need to identify it
in in your written testimony you noted
the importance of using illness
surveillance systems can you tell us a
bit more about how we are applying
existing systems to this virus and our
u.s. public health agencies developing
new surveillance illness surveillance
systems specific to coronavirus yeah
this is really important this is really
one of the most important components
from CDC's perspective in the recently
requested supplemental we have an
excellent surveillance system in this
nation for flu we have multiple
surveillance system as you just
mentioned we have the illness we have
multiple and rather than recreate the
wheel what we have proposed and we've
actually begun this in in US and at
least initiated is we're really adapting
our entire respiratory disease
surveillance systems and now interfacing
coronavirus 19 and you know I'm very
hopeful in the next 812 weeks we will be
in a position that we will have your
your flu surveillance system if you
follow that and you're gonna have your
national coronavirus system I'm more
interested in this as I'm hoping is the
canary in the mine field in the mines
that I can I can see when and if we're
getting community I don't have to wait
to an individual gets hospitalized and
is on a ventilator you know I have to be
honest with you we don't know what we're
gonna find when we start this but we're
very anxious to get this broad front of
our surveillance system using all the
systems that we have right now for
respiratory disease and get that
operational as soon as possible and to
be able to see the trends that we may be
seeing that in fact demonstrate that
we're looking at potentially an outbreak
in a locality or in a state absolutely
and then and then be able to put the
full power of the Public Health approach
of early of case recognition kind of
isolation contact tracing to try to make
sure that that cluster is contained and
do you have the financial resources and
the employee
capacity for for this surveillance
system and what you need into the future
well I will say that's one of our major
components of the supplemental that was
put forward I think was to be able for
us to roll this out nationally great
thank you so much to the other witnesses
I know I concentrated my question on dr.
Redfield but I do appreciate your time
and your your your presence here today
thank you I yield back
thank you mrs. Bamberger the gentleman
from California mr. Liu's recognized to
question witness for five minutes
Thank You chairman Bera for calling this
important hearing thank you dr. Redfield
for your public service including your
service to US military the Washington
Post published an article headline is a
faulty CDC coronavirus test delays
monitoring of diseases spread so my
first question to you is does the CDC's
test for kkona or virus work yes okay
what is the error rate on that test so
we created a test really very rapidly
based on the sequence of the virus
within really a week of the sequence
being published and it's a PCR based
test and the way it was designed at CDC
was it actually measures three different
if you will components I just need to
know the error rate well if you know it
yeah the problem was in when the test
was sent to the States one of the
components had a contaminant in it
that's what had to be corrected the test
at CDC works fine when it was given to a
manufacturer to scale up for the study
that has a C's he fixed it it has been
corrected and there are tests that are
being shipped out as we speak okay so in
fact the first test they didn't work
first test works because it was
developed at CDC and it works fine I did
we test everyone in the country when we
see it when the manufacturer scaled to
send to the states when the states got
it it could tell positives they could
call negatives but because of one of the
contaminants in the control there was
another group that was we don't know if
it's positive or negative was
inconclusive and at that time the FDA
requested that we not use that test and
have people send it to CDC where the
initial Lots that we made
were quite functional and there was no
contaminant and that's the test we
continue to use today there are now over
ice I just needed some test works
current tests were ok great so it's been
reporting out that 48 countries have
chrono various cases in Italy it's
skyrocketed now to 650 cases South Korea
has now 70 hundred cases as you yourself
stated there are more new cases in South
Korea than in China why is it that were
only testing people who have traveled to
China that seems to make not a lot of
sense to me well when this outbreak
originally occurred on table right now
that one occurred right now why don't we
test well we're a volte South Korea
Italy travelled to the 11 European
countries where there now coronavirus
cases we're continuing the travel
restrictions that were initiated and
just how about testing people why don't
you expand the test because there's a
person in Northern California that
doctors recommended get the test and CDC
said no because the person had a
traveler China that's just really stupid
because we know this is expanded way
beyond China 48 countries every
continent except Antarctica has these
cases we really should be testing people
not just those who have traveled with
China can you commit to expanding the
test to beyond those that have just
traveled to China if they have the
symptoms they look like they have
coronavirus congressman I mentioned
earlier I think before you were here
just so you know we initially had a
geographic restriction we have changed
that we've posted there's a no
geographic district ssin that if a
clinician or a Health Department
official considers the corona virus and
the differential diagnosis that now
meets our criteria once you make that
change we made that well yesterday we
did it and posted it today thank you for
making that change okay so in terms of
transmission because early you said
people shouldn't be afraid my sending
based on the articles of reuters
reported that corona virus contagion
rate makes it hard to control and there
these two scientific studies that show
essentially each person effect with the
corona viruses passing disease on to
between two and three other people on
average a current transmission rates
and they've you got this long incubation
period potentially 14 days or more
you could have an exponential explosion
of cases rather quickly suggest an Italy
isn't that correct I think we've seen
that obviously in Italy Korea and Iran
and and and and yeah so so this person
Northern California who didn't travel
China where we don't know where he got
the corona virus he could have passed on
to two more people who pass it on to two
more people who pass it on to more
people so there could be a whole cluster
of cases but until as of yesterday we
don't know because we weren't testing
anyone who didn't travel with China am i
understanding this correctly the current
public health evaluation of the case in
in in the Chairman's district is being
led by the state public health system of
California and we're supporting that we
have a large number of contacts that
have been evaluated that are being
isolated that are being tested to really
look at the fullest extent of the
potential transmission around that case
thank you i'ma conclude by saying Donald
Trump has attempted to minimize the
corona virus outbreak there's an article
in a Daily Beast titled coronaviruses
makes corona virus may explode in the
u.s. overnight just like in Italy
requests that when the data and science
contradicts what Donald Trump says that
you follow the data and the science I
yield back
yeah I could just say that I commit that
CDC is science-based data-driven
services organization and that's one of
the prides that I have to be the
director now to be in a science-based
data-driven but most importantly service
organization thank you let me recognize
the gentleman from California mr.
Sherman thank you China failed to well
actually hid this disease at the
beginning China continues to try to
exclude Taiwan from the w-h-o there are
a number of things China could be doing
we need Chinese cooperation to start
clinical trials dr. Redfield are we
getting it
there is a drug called reduce severe
that's now in clinical trials in China
and Japan and and it's been extended
there's actually in to the United States
to the repatriated individuals there are
similarities vague similarities to the
flu as flu is often seasonal is this
disease our president has said oh it's
gonna be gone by April how confident are
we that transmission will be
substantially less when the winter is
over it's unknown
there are various treatments that are
used for flu such as theraflu is there
any reason to think that there's some
chance that that would be helpful in
reducing the effect of the disease not
for the corona virus 19 and likewise the
SARS vaccine would that provide any
protection it's unlikely that the
cross-reactive but the methods that they
were used to develop that vaccine is the
reason the doctor found she's been able
to accelerate the vaccinees developing
good and what's the earliest we could
have a vaccine
well dr. Fauci said one one-year days 18
months if everything goes well got you
see how well are we cooperating with
China today are they providing the
information we need and our people on
the ground mr. Fritz Thank You
congressman I've pointed out a bit
earlier that we did get a very we've got
good faith cooperation from Chinese
officials as we worked to send in and
get out our five plane loads of the
vacuum that I'm not talking about yet
but so I only have people on the ground
at the epicenter of this epidemic
getting information that's helping dr.
Redford red field do his job I'll defer
to my colleague on the actual are you
getting what you need from China
I have regular discussions with my
counterpart George Allen head of CDC we
do have a CDC a US a CDC that's embedded
into the China CDC so we are having
daily interactions I have a team of
respiratory experts that are there
working there at a scientific level
we're having good dialogue but
congressman if I could I would point out
that you know secretary Pompey and
others have also of course made it clear
that China's allergy to freedom of
speech freedom of expression etc etc
I've been obviously had a very negative
impact lots of local officials was to
try to keep it under wraps and the
failure to be a free society that's why
this thing got going and we're now in a
position that perhaps could have been
avoided if China had a different policy
toward a free expression
versus hide things and hope they that
you can keep them under wraps let's see
why does the administration request for
additional funding rely overwhelmingly
on transferring funds from other
disease-fighting accounts dr. Redfield
the dude do we need to spend any money
on a bola can we just grab that money no
problem though obviously we can't we
have an ongoing a bola outbreak right
now in the Congo I really can't do you
think it's wise then to take all the
money that we had appropriated for Ebola
and not spend any money on a bola I
really can't comment on the budgetary
decisions that were made are you doing
useful work that will save lives or may
save lives
with regard to Ebola are you if we if we
leave the money in the budget will you
spend it effectively in ways that sell
painful we currently have an ongoing
Ebola outbreak in the eastern DRC where
we have a substantial number of CDC
people deployed and we are if you will
and I say this and knock on wood
we're finally close to winning okay
we're down to really in the last week we
didn't have a
case it's so we now we now project based
on our models that we might actually end
this outbreak by the end of June but
obviously when instability happens again
we could be right back where we were two
months ago so and if this a bola
outbreak expands in the eastern Congo it
could be a threat to the United States
just as a Chinese locust entered problem
has been a threat to the United States
and even to California well we've been
fortunate in with Ebola in that there's
very little movement from the Ebola
eastern Congo where this outbreak is in
the United States but we obviously have
had to invest significantly in what we
call exit screening from the Congo as
we've dealt this as you know we've been
in this outbreak now we're almost about
to start the third year if we don't
fight Ebola in Africa does that mean
Americans are safe and everything's fine
and you're assuring me that we can just
not worry about Ebola and and everybody
and we're not gonna have a problem this
year next year I think one of the most
important things our nation can do is
build a robust global health security
capacity all right so that we can detect
prevent and respond to these outbreaks
at their source and this is exactly what
we're doing with Ebola and the more that
we can expand that capacity and I
believe strongly it's a core mission of
CDC where the tip of the spear to
identify these infectious disease
threats and obviously we appreciate your
continued support in that regard because
what we're seeing with the corona virus
is just another example of why it's so
important then we have global leadership
in the ability to detect prevent and
respond to these outbreaks I would just
comment that the outbreak of this corona
virus demonstrates the importance of
your work and the absolute folly of
pulling the plug on some of your work
because of an unwillingness to fund the
additional work that we need to do for
the corona virus with that I yield back
thank you I'm gonna use the Chairman's
prerogative to ask a couple questions
cuz I feel bad mr. Brownlee dr. wat
Walters I'm
I appreciate your coming down and see I
don't don't know if I'm doing a favor
asking you questions or if the goal as
witness is a slide out of here with no
questions but I appreciate your coming
down you know mr. Brownlee I hear your
concerns and we'll continue an ongoing
conversation about flexibility and
consular functions I've been honest in
my concerns with the administration in
announcing travel restrictions for
individuals coming from China I
understand the rationale and reasoning
behind it but also have can some
concerns about whether it's gonna do
what we hope it does with regards to
containment mr. Brownlee going forward
though are we considering similar
measures against other nations and if we
are under what specific circumstances
and then the last question would be as a
CDC in the State Department issued
travel advisories for countries who have
been impacted by coronavirus what
specific objective criteria are we using
to make these determinations maybe
doctor I'd feel that's a question for
you mr. Brown thank you very much for
your question chairman with regard to
further to 12 possible proclamations
this remains the prerogative of the
White House they are gathering
information from all available sources
as to whether further restrictions might
be necessary to help contain the virus
as dr. Redfield has noted now several
times we are still in the containment
phase whether CDC and other health care
provider public health authorities will
recommend that is beyond my scope with
regard to travel advisories this too is
something we we revisit consulate
constantly the Bureau of Consular
Affairs we are looking at a variety of
different issues with regard to any
single country health is one crime is
another risk of terrorism another
natural disaster etc we look at
information that we draw from a variety
of sources the UN provides some info
nation on health issues we talk to the
the Bureau of Diplomatic Security with
regard to that the crime and terrorism
risks we pull information from the
intelligence community in other words
from a variety of different sources we
talk to our friends the the five
like-minded countries UK Austria cetera
we gather all this information we use a
fact-based metric matrix to try to
decide whether we're going to rank a
country one two three or four great I
hope that answers dr. Redfield the
purpose of the CDC levels is really a
different purpose it's really for public
health purposes only and we actually
have three levels that you know makes it
confusing we have the first which is
just an alert to let the American public
know that there is an ongoing infectious
disease issue and so right now for the
alert Singapore Taiwan Thailand Vietnam
once we see that there is significant
human to human transmission so it's not
just a there's something going on there
we go to what we call a level 1 and
right now that's Hong Kong when there's
actually multiple clusters of human to
human transmission then we go to a level
2 and that really tells people
particularly if you have you're older or
if you have any comorbidities you really
ought to reconsider travel and that
right now for us is Iran Italy in Japan
now this changes every day as you said
and then level 3 we're telling people
this is when we have broad
community-based transmission we're
telling the American public that we
recommend they don't travel so those are
our levels and we reevaluate them every
day based on the data that we see of
what's happening in the country at the
time really around human to human
transmission how isolated it is how
broad it is and and right now obviously
in Korea we have very broad transmission
throughout the country it's moved to a
level 3 China very broad transmission
out the country but you should
anticipate that these are going to
continue to change they can go up or
down
I wouldn't be surprised if we don't have
changes even in the next 24-48 hours
based on what's happening in these
countries Thank You dr. Redfield um in
mr. fritz I know you're on a tight
timeline so you know we appreciate your
being being here if you have to to leave
the panel thank you if I could you know
ask dr. Walters a question because again
I appreciate your coming down here and
making himself available to us you know
in thinking through the evacuation of
some of the Americans on the diamond
princess and and so forth you know there
were there were reports that positive
testing patients and and again yeah it
may be that those results weren't
communicated or I'd be curious but some
of the positive testing patients were
commingled with negative testing
patients and just curious how that might
have happened and then how we avoid that
happening in the future
Thank You mr. chairman thank you for the
for the question but timeline matters so
the diamond the decision to evacuate
American citizens from the diamond
princess was was not based on you know
there's there's a there's an outbreak of
kovat 19 on their ship the decision was
based on there was evidence of ongoing
person-to-person transmission this this
was a problem that was not getting
better was getting worse and despite the
best efforts of the government of Japan
once the decision was made that it was
safer to move these American citizens
many of whom were in an age range that
puts them at the greatest risk we've we
followed protocol this was the I think
the sixth flight that we had done in
like two weeks each of those individuals
each of the 329 individuals that we took
off that ship were evaluated by a
medical officer from either the State
Department or Health and Human Services
asper within that 24 hour period the
embassy in Tokyo had reached out to the
ministry of health welfare and labor and
asked that all lab results be reported
by 4:30 that afternoon the evaluator
were done the evacuees then were handed
from the Government of Japan over to the
care of the United States government
they were disembarked from the ship they
were loaded onto buses and this was to
be one single movement of 15 buses from
the ship to the airport it was only once
those evacuees were 329 people on 15
buses and in the minutes after midnight
on the docks at Yokohama that a an
official from the government of japan
approached the the embassy personnel
with a list and on that list 416 names
and of the 16 names 14 people were
manifested and somewhere on 15 different
buses and the buses were already in
movement in the movement from the docks
Yokohama to the airport there was some
discussion hey we've got this problem
we're working through it that's only a
40 or 45 minute movement once they
arrived at the airport the 14 were
identified in a way that was efficient
but protected their privacy and it's
important to remember none of these
individuals had symptoms they were not
coughing sneezing you know they didn't
they didn't have fevers that had all
been confirmed they were removed from
the bus they were taken to the only
place now imagine it's morning is
breaking at that airport it's raining
these are 60 to 80 year-old American
citizens that are helped off the buses
and put into an isolation area aboard
the aircraft the way the aircraft is set
up the airflow moves from the nose to
the tail in them so sort of at most
at-risk areas at near the tail of the
aircraft
we had already partitioned off as we had
in previous flights an area that to
protect other passengers from any
contagion that might be with those folks
and they were placed there and then
there was a robust interagency
discussion much has been made about the
discussion but at the end of the day we
reached consensus and there was
consensus between the Department our
partners that we rely on from Health and
Human Services State Department and
others that yes these are evacuees yes
they've been placed into the care of the
US government yes they are contained and
they pose no further threat
and with that we brought them back to
the finest quarantine facility in the
world to receive the best care available
great thank you for that explanation I
know I'm the ranking member had
additional questions yeah in this first
State Department because we heard over
in China how the hell I think it was
1600 health workers came down and they
were sick we had talked to our
ambassador from Cambodia we had a
discussion with him today and he was
saying what a stellar response our state
department did of working 24/7 at six
different locations moving people out
what kind of protections we have for our
state partner and State Department
personnel because I know when we go on
Codell as you guys work your tails off
and we appreciate it and we want to make
sure you have the coverage and the
health care that you need are you you
feel adequate yes sir thank you for the
for the comments and the question here's
what I would say this this is an
international emergency with Sigma and
domestic risk but in 220 locations
around the world we have a workforce of
75,000 people some of whom are in
countries that have active cases others
are in countries that made tomorrow find
themselves with a crisis we learned our
lessons in 2004 we learned our lessons
again in in 1415 and we're thankful to
Congress for the support we've had in
the preparedness side of this there is
PPE at every embassy our our health care
workers a workforce of almost 700 in all
these locations are well educated they
are well prepared we continue to look at
our resource requirements and we
continue to look at our authorities not
just to take care of American citizens
to the chief of mission personnel we're
really in that global picture to protect
Americans oh and we've we feel confident
that if you know an embassy were to come
down and the workers get exposed that we
can get the supplies needed in there if
it's in an area that is more remote
where we don't normally have good health
care maybe that we can get it in there
in a sufficient numbers we feel like
we're protected there right so we have
there's two parts to that answer the
first part is the same aviation contract
that made these evacuations possible is
the same aviation
contract that makes delivery of critical
supplies possible the second part to
that is actually a greater risk and the
greater risk here is when you look at
the way we do medical evacuations a
chief of mission personnel around the
world they don't typically come back to
the United States they go to medevac
centers with with established
relationships in South Africa or UK
those countries are now making it more
and more difficult in a way that you can
understand to bring non UK citizens or
non you know South African citizens in
if there's any risk that they have Kovan
19 so we continue to work with our
international partners to keep those
diplomatic platforms open so that dr.
Redfield's teams have a place to work
and the resources and relationships to
do it but still be able to medevac our
chief of mission people home when the
time comes okay thank you dr. Redfield
again there's this cloud of lack of
transparency that we keep getting from
China what signals can we see from China
to see what the real extent of damage is
behind the containment you know the
National People's Congress meeting has
recently been cancelled I mean that's a
pretty strong signal to show that that
threat is really they're really that
concerned about it as they should be but
then with the people over there not
getting you know an open press where
they can get reliable information do we
feel like they're being forthright with
you I mean you're working with Amana
more of a scientific platform do you
feel comfort comfortable with the
information you're getting from my
colleagues a scientific interaction
we're having with our CDC colleagues and
from the Chinese CDC I'm very
comfortable with it what we have as I
said I have my own director of the
American CDC in China they were there
regularly interacting so at the
scientific level we're having
collaboration I really can't really
comment beyond that I will say it's
worth noting that they've probably
introduced some of the most aggressive
containment striation strategies that
we've ever seen and they were seen on
planet I assure you the world you know
but and I and I would like to say just
though people are
feeling better that there's a reduced
number of cases in China just last night
if that's accurately reported exactly
but but even then it was 434 people and
and over it's somewhere between 25 and
30 deaths last night so they still have
a major problem despite everything
they've done in mitigation
I want to throw one thing out I don't
really expect an answer on this being a
veterinarian we've seen the porcine
viral diarrhea syndrome broke out
several years ago within a year it was
in America lost about 300,000 South in
America African swine fever broke out I
think was May of 2018 I can't remember
the exact date we've not seen that here
but we do know this it is a very Hardy
virus that can be transmitted in
different fomites it can resist freezing
it can resist heat and it can make the
trans
shipping from China to the United States
in containers in different materials
whether it's feed packaging and so this
is something we need to be alert through
a fost or USDA through CDC that we're
monitoring these things better than we
ever have before because that's a port
of entry that we might not even be
looking about we're looking at people
but we also need to look at containers
and fomites coming in that way yeah the
only comment I would make for this fire
is just so you know we are aggressively
evaluating how long this virus can
survive and be infectious and we're on
copper and steel it's pretty typical
it's really pretty much about two hours
but I will say that another service is
cardboard or plastic it's it's longer
and so we are looking at this because we
don't know the role of foam i
transmission now it's it's I don't think
it's gonna impact cargo okay unlike
maybe some of the other viruses that
you've talked about but I do think that
it may have contributed to the huge
outbreak we saw on that Diamond Princess
it may not have all been aerosolized it
could have been fomites so we are
aggressively evaluating that to
understand how well this virus survives
in different conditions we'd appreciate
you two keeping us informed on that
thank you burger has additional question
yes Thank You mr. chairman
since we have been in this hearing
there's a breaking story with the
Washington Post and I don't expect that
you all have seen it yet but it is
there's a whistleblower report that
senior HHS official who oversees workers
at the administration for Children and
Families has now filed a whistle-blower
report that HHS employees were sent to
an airplane hangar to meet evacuated
Americans at the March Air Force Base in
Riverside and they were not given any
PPE you or protective equipment while
they were interacting directly with
those who were potentially impacted I
raise this recognizing that that we're
dealing with different agencies here
present today but I think this speaks to
a general concern it's a little bit of a
follow up to a congressman Beres
question related to whether or not State
Department officers have what they need
to stay safe and I would so I'll pose
that question but then also wanted to
make sure to make the point that this is
deeply concerning because as we're
dealing with a significant outbreak
something that is personally causing
great fear in our communities among
individuals we need to ensure that our
constituents have faith that the
administration of the US government is
doing everything possible and there's
already some concerns about whether or
not that's the case and what how people
can keep themselves safe and so finding
out that the u.s. government might have
put its own personnel in harm's way is
is deeply concerning to me so if you
could comment both whether or not your
agencies are ensuring that their
personnel are safe and then comment on
you know what we can do in light of this
when we're back in our districts and
people are saying how can we trust the
government to keep us safe if this is
happening to its own people I'd love
your comments on that you know thank you
for for the question and the concern I
can I can speak having been on those
missions
and and certainly and the the first trip
out of Wuhan the second the third the
diamond princess and and based on a
relationship that I've had with HHS
asper and CDC dating back to 2014 every
precaution has been taken so it was at
your experience that you did not witness
any individuals who were not wearing PPE
no I can say unequivocally that everyone
involved with those evacuations was
appropriately equipped and trained okay
Wow and I don't see I don't seek to be
argumentative with you sir I'm reading
what's up breaking news in the
Washington Post but that is good to hear
and then specifically with State
Department officials and and the
availability of protective gear and the
attention to detail there we we take
every precaution we have the equipment
and the training that we need to do this
safely thank you and would you care to
comment as well mr. friendly yes please
my consular colleagues in China Japan
and elsewhere had been working on an
ongoing basis with with people so for
example in Japan there are still
100-plus US citizens from the diamond
princess in the country a number of
those are hospitalized we are regularly
engaging with those people but we're
doing so in a safe fashion taking
professional advice so whereas initially
some of the business we're taking place
in person that became cumbersome because
they were having to suit up now these
visitors taking place in a telephonic
basis I have here a photograph I gave
the Chairman a copy of it that shows my
colleagues standing on the on the the
key side as they were processing people
coming off the Diamond Princess they
were properly taken care I can see the
photo from here that they are I'll leave
you a copy they are equipped and then
the the general concern about you know
again this is just report that is
breaking news the veracity of it will be
determined later but it is in the news
and people are reading and it's adding
to this story
are there other Arthur comments that you
all would like to make related to
ensuring that our constituents the
people we represent have faith that
we're handling this at all involved
agencies are
handling this virus and and concerns and
Menino in the way that it should be
handled and and just in light of what
might otherwise be some concerning news
what I would say is that the psychology
in dealing with highly infectious
disease is often worse than the
pathology that we have the best medical
care in the world and whether it's Ebola
or coronavirus the American healthcare
system is ready to receive and ready to
take care of our health care workers and
our public from the State Department's
perspective we have a workforce that is
at the frontline
we are we are happy to be there to
facilitate the relationships that are
going to be critical for containing this
overseas whether it's a delivery of
foreign assistance or the exchange of
technical information what I tell my
family is that you live in the best
country in the world and that that
people who know how to do this are in
positions where they can advise state
local and international health care
workers thank you I thank you for the
for the indulgence of the second
question mr. chairman into the witnesses
thank you so much for all of the work I
know that you are putting in on this
thank you for your continued service to
our country and to keep us all safe and
healthy I truly appreciate it I yield
back
thank you let me recognize the gentleman
from California mr. Sherman
dr. what's your best estimate as to the
mortality rate of this disease among
those who are healthy and under age 65
again I think the really the most
important thing in that scenario under
65 and healthy is whether your health
system functional or not so as we've
seen with the Wuhan Health System valve
again healthy health system healthy
human under age 65 yeah my constituents
yeah I think again
you know we don't have the data but I
suspect if you look at the mortality
rate of this disease outside of of China
we're probably looking right now is
somewhere around a half a percent right
but again we'll have to see more data to
really be clear on that in seasonal flu
has a mortality rate of about 0.1% one
four thousand point one per thousand or
0.1% point one percent I'm sorry yeah
point one percent the Chinese are
telling us that there's a decline should
why should we believe them doctor I
think that there probably is a decline
again I do think some of the mitigation
strategies are starting to have impact
particularly out of whoa Bay most the
cases now are in the wool Bay Area I
want to ask you about masks it's funny I
went onto Amazon buy 50 masks is 50
bucks which and it's you know they're
not very heavy it was less than a pound
and then Amazon wants to charge an
additional $400 for shipping and
handling needless to say we'll be in
touch with Amazon on this but the I
don't think that Amazon has ever charged
400 dollars to ship a box and I'm not on
a rush basis actually a delay for say
two weeks from now one less than a pound
four hundred dollars shipping and
handling seemed an extraordinary charge
I but you know given mr. Bezos is need
for food and the necessities of life I
can understand we see pictures from all
over the world people wearing these
masks who should wear the masks in the
United States yeah as I mentioned
earlier the the mask the n95 mask really
need to be reserved for health care
providers that are taking care of these
patients in the hospital as well as
confirmed individuals that are in home
isolation to minimize the spread while
they're in home isolation
we would not recommend the American
public go out and get these masks and I
asked protect the person wearing it or
protect others from the person wearing
it well there's really the issue here is
to protect the individual who is being
exposed to someone who has the pathogen
and and we believe that that's where the
mass should be a lot of the people you
see wearing these masks they're really
not gonna have a functional impact
whatsoever in terms of transmission
these surgical masks that you see
everybody wearing on the even when I you
know was traveling today here in the
city I saw people again and even in our
own city wearing masks some of them do
it that have a cold or an illness that
they think it might minimize them I
would tell those people to stay home
that would be more effective things
trying to feel that you have to go to
work and wear a mask so I think this is
CDC has a on its website really good
guidance on the appropriate use of masks
and I encourage people to go look at it
it looks like the Chinese have had a
decline they've dealt with extraordinary
lockdowns of entire areas should we be
locking down any neighborhood where we
find that someone what what level of
lock downs do we need if any yeah the
the backbone of our response right now
and really the most important part of
our multi-layered response even though
sometimes people don't recognize it
because it's not like travel
restrictions or screening at airports
the backbone is the American medical
community in public health community as
I mentioned of our 15 cases that we
diagnosed in this country 14 of them
were diagnosed by our medical public
health community so I'm going to
maintain confidence on early diagnosis
isolation and in contact rate as our
major mechanism to test to test for this
is it's sufficient to just take people's
temperature as they were doing or does
is it contagious before it's symptomatic
and do we need to give a lot a lot of
people blood tests
yes so the issue on how infectious this
virus is at different states of
symptomatology is still unknown but we
do know that you can transmit this virus
before symptoms does that contribute
meaningfully we don't know and I think
that's what we're trying to learn
clearly we and CDC is working on another
other test which the Chairman would
understand we're trying to develop
serological tests so that we can
understand the extent like in China
right now what they're doing is they're
measuring the act of virus and that's
what we're doing but that doesn't really
tell us what the denominator is of who's
really been infected you need a
serological tests to do that we're
currently working on oh I know the chair
the Chairman understands what you're
saying you're saying we want to test to
see which people have been exposed have
the antibodies and may have been
asymptomatic throughout the whole
process yes please didn't know they had
the disease yes that you see no you're
not their number up here who understands
it
I yield back well thank you once again I
just want to recognize and say I
appreciate the the service that to our
country and obviously this is a very
fluid situation it did just want to make
reference to the breaking story that mr.
Bamberger identified I'm fully confident
that we do everything we can to protect
our personnel and our workers and as we
were evacuating folks from China you
know putting them on airplanes bringing
the our citizens back back home it does
sound like there was someone who did see
some personnel that did not have
protective gear and we're released you
know I hate to use the term
whistleblower because it's gotten
politicized but it is important that if
there are folks that are raising issues
and I do feel that it's very important
for this body to say publicly we want to
encourage folks who see things for the
sake of bettering ourselves those
whistleblowers are those individual
raising issues we are fully committed to
protecting them and we fully want folks
that are seeing things to feel
comfortable and protected from from
coming up not commenting on whether this
story is accurate or inaccurate but I am
commenting on the fact that it is
important for folks that see things to
identify them and not fear retribution
for coming forward that is our law that
is the way this process works dr.
Redfield I appreciate your coming up to
the hill and keeping us informed you
know again in conversation with my
colleagues at UC Davis we look forward
to working very closely with the CDC and
you know as one doctor to another you
know as we work through the regulatory
process to speed up our testing
capabilities and the availability of
diagnostic tests throughout this country
we look forward to working with well
you're not the one holding it at
necessarily bay we do look forward to
speeding up that regulatory process to
make sure we get these tests out and are
able to do it and again I appreciate
updating the the folks said that we are
testing I do think that is is going to
be helpful and and trusting our doctors
that are on the front line if they do
suspect coronavirus being able to get
that test in the Jemez i just want to
make one comment
for the record that we have been working
very closely with the fda they have been
very supportive I just want to make sure
they're but they're operating operating
within the regulatory framework that we
have and I think the point that I wanted
to make is that the loss of laboratory
development tests to be used when we're
developing new tests and responding to
new emergencies I think is something
that should be relooked at that and
again thank you and thank thank all
three views walls your colleagues at HHS
USAID Homeland Security for regularly
coming up to the hill to brief members
of Congress and again this is fluid so
let's maintain close contact and
dialogue and with that this hearing is
adjourned
[Music]